so since you think that the wealthy or
maybe everyone has a moral obligation to
give back to society one of the debates
that came up in our class is whether
society can just encourage the wealthy
to give their money back or whether it
would be morally okay to have something
like the government forcing the wealthy
to give back say after they die what are
your thoughts on that I think that I I
would tend to keep I would tend to keep
the government out of it because by
definition then it will get political
right so and I think the politics of
giving is a bit rocky and something I
struggle with personally so I think that
I mean I'm absolutely in favor of
raising taxes on the wealthy and in that
way contributing to government resources
and civil society development but i
think that forcing like a like a
philanthropy tax or something like that
on some of these death I'm not sure that
that would be an effective use of those
dollars because would that person then
like would the person be allowed to say
where it goes to or they would just have
to give you know five percent or
something to any charitable cause I mean
you can set it up either way we talked
about both scenarios in class and
whether one would be more acceptable
than the other or whether or not is
acceptable what do you think I'm not a
huge fan of the idea in part because I
think it would be great if everybody
just everyone was giving but I don't
think you can legislate people into
being a good people yeah yeah yeah I
think I think that's a good I think
that's a good point it's yeah forcing
somebody to have a belief that you want
them to have and that's not American
right supposedly